up until about half a year ago Anna was
still living with a self-proclaimed
Islamic state in Syria and although
she's now back home in Kosovo she
insists on wearing her niqab or full
body veil while ninety percent of the
population in Kosovo are Sunni Muslim
few women wear the niqab most people
here practise a more liberal form of
Islam any time I go outside they look at
us like a UFO aliens I can see it's
bizarre for them to see us like this but
for me it's not a problem
Anna stayed until is lost its last
holdout bagus in a military strike
approved by federal authorities we meet
her at a lake outside Kosovo's capital
Pristina like all female attorneys she
lives under house arrest awaiting trial
Anna as the first Kosovar attorney to
speak on camera about her experience we
wanted to know what she thought about
the beheadings and other reported crimes
against humanity committed in the name
of the Islamic state but Ana avoided our
questions and focus instead on her own
suffering but the airstrikes when they
came they just bombed a house you know a
big building there were kids there there
were women mothers everything at the
Pristina Airport one night in April
Europe's youngest country and one of its
poorest brought 32 women seventy four
children and four male fighters back
home all of them had been imprisoned in
Kurdish camps in northern Syria after
the military defeat of the Islamic state
the operation was a strategic move for
the cause of our government based on the
belief that back home under official
observation the returnees would pose
less of a security risk than if they
remained abroad the aim is to
reintegrate all of them into society
including the men who were sent to
prison right away meanwhile the
authorities are closely monitoring the
women and children and offering them
counseling they didn't see any
resistance
from them to be part of our programs and
maybe this also is due that due to the
fact that they know that it was Kosovo
authorities who took the decision to
repatriate them in Kosovo otherwise they
would have remained in the conflict zone
the cause of our approach is unique no
other European government has undertaken
similar steps rich Western democracies
such as Germany France and Britain have
so far rejected any organized return of
their citizens who joined the
self-proclaimed Islamic state the fear
of not being able to control their
attorneys appears to be too great Ana
tells us she didn't know what she was
getting herself into when she followed
her husband to Syria in 2014 I was going
to go somewhere else with my husband I
didn't know I was going there my husband
prepared everything for me to go there
but didn't tell me suddenly I found
myself in Syria after her husband died
in battle she married another fighter
whose fate remains unclear early this
year after the military defeat of the
Islamic state Ana surrendered like
thousands of others she ended up in the
alcohol refugee camp a living hell she
says and I cannot understand why other
European countries are refusing to take
their citizens back we are human we are
people if someone makes mistake one time
we shouldn't just leave them like that
the women they are so sensitive the kids
what is their fault you know so we
should help them
Friday prayer in a mosque in central
Pristina after the ethnic wars of the
1990s religious organizations and
charities from Saudi Arabia and other
Gulf states had a growing influence in
Kosovo with them came a much more
conservative school of Islam one that
taught the supremacy of the Sharia law
and ideas of violent jihad more than
four hundred young Kosovars joined
extremist groups in Syria and Iraq
between 2012 and 2017 the highest rate
per head in Europe the authorities are
convinced that the Saudi influence was
the driving force behind their
radicalization I believe that the idea
of the NGOs and extremists that brought
ideology here was to change the very
cold value of the society to introduce
political Islam in Kosovo and also to
establish a network that one day they
may become also they may have also
political power and become a political
factor the Imam of this mosque in
central Pristina which itself is
considered to be a rather conservative
points to other reasons than just fara
communities in our country many young
people didn't have any future prospects
over the last twenty years
the main reasons for this the poor
economic situation a social state of the
country and the lack of prospects in
general but we should not deny the role
YouTube that's played in radicalization
I would like to point out that these
people have not been radicalized by
their religious representatives visitor
to life at all we are on our way to
another of the 32 female attorneys Laura
agreed to an interview only on the
condition of total anonymity we are not
allowed to show where and how she lives
her first two husbands are dead the
third imprisoned in a camp like Ana
Laura spent several years in Syria I was
very young I didn't think I just
followed my husband I expected something
totally different in life that is why I
feel betrayed it was a mistake
war is not a place for women and
children war is bad for everyone I would
never go there again so far Laura
doesn't have any concrete plans for the
future just hopes I want to live as a
free person integrated into society I
hope that the people will accept me as I
am
even with my hijab Laura Anna and the
other women psychiatrist fabu not Ofili
knows them all she is in charge of the
government's rehabilitation and
reintegration program for the female
returnees and their children due to
doctor-patient confidentiality Tafel I
won't say whether she thinks some of the
women might possibly be dangerous she
and her team talked to the returnees on
a regular basis in the clinic and in
their homes all the women and children
who returned from Syria were traumatized
they came back from a war zone where
they witnessed cruel crimes and heavy
bombing which has led to trauma and
post-traumatic stress disorder PTSD
there have been a number of activities
specially designed to help the children
cope with what they have been through
young innocent victims of a war their
parents dragged them into back in a safe
environment they can finally play like
other children the older kids just
started regular school after the summer
holidays it is too early to talk about
greater improvements but we are seeing
some progress back to normal life in
Kosovo just in Kosovo
catch anak about 50 kilometers south of
Pristina the small town of about 10,000
inhabitants at the border to Macedonia
was considered one of the hot beds of
radicalization about two dozen people
are said to have left for the war zones
in Syria and Iraq from kitronik
in the surrounding area alone on the
streets people seem supportive of taking
them back don't need any gap in the city
they have made mistakes and we have to
help them reintegrate into our society
these are our people it was a good
decision to bring them back I support
this initiative these people shouldn't
have gone to Syria we are in Kosovo on
the Balkans
we don't need Wars we have been through
war ourselves I don't think these people
have come back to do harm here like they
did there that's why we shouldn't
exclude them Anna wants to leave the
past behind she says she feels accepted
by her family and neighborhood no one
talks to her about her time in Syria and
are still making sense of why she's
under house arrest we came from a place
of war it is very normal they are
investigating us but in the end they
will understand that we aren't at fault
we didn't do anything
maybe our mistake is that we were there
we lived there Anna is still convinced
that she didn't do anything wrong but
ultimately that's up to Kosovo's
authorities to decide